manquent les via le plan hercules et la
facture d'électricité pourquoi tel
explosé depuis 15 ans et pourquoi le
tarif réglementé at-il encore augmenté
le 1er février l'ouverture à la
concurrence de 2007 en est elle
responsable
d'ailleurs à quoi servait-il tous ces
producteurs indépendants que produit
style et le black out évité de justesse
que 8 janvier dernier qui a failli
priver d'électricité des millions
d'européens est ce que c'est la faute
des énergies renouvelables que ce soit
l'éolien ou le solaire et risque-t-elle
ces énergies renouvelables de provoquer
dans l'avenir des pénuries d'électricité
à répétition et faut-il dans ce cas
réduire la part du nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique alors qu'il est bien
plus efficace est tout aussi économe en
émissions de co2 dans l'atmosphère vrai
pour débattre de toutes ces questions
qu'on pose ici et là nous avons invité
marc boudier
vous avez été directeur d'edf pour
l'europe responsable du développement et
des participations du groupe dans la
plupart des pays européens
vous êtes passé depuis à la concurrence
puisque vous avez été nommé en 2010 est
président du conseil de surveillance du
groupe de chauffage urbain
korian c'est vous êtes depuis 2013
président de l'association française
indépendante de l'électricité et du gaz
la fièvre qui représente donc les
producteurs indépendants
alors pour qu'on comprenne bien matt
boudier tous ces producteurs
indépendants ils produisent quoi écouter
plus généralement à quoi servait-il
alors il essaye de produire dans les
domaines où on les autorise à avoir des
capacités de production c'est-à-dire
nulle nucléaire ni les drôles
électricité qui sont quand même les
moyens principaux auxquels on peut
penser en dehors du renouvelable
alors ils ont quand même construit un
certain nombre d'installations
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit et en
particulier tout ce qui était les cycles
combinés à gaz qui ont un rôle important
on pourra y revenir dans la flexibilité
du système électrique
c'est essentiellement des groupes
indépendants qui les ont construits
ils ont aussi comme je lé d'y participer
à des investissements dans la
transformation de certaines
installations je pense
par exemple la transformation pour aix
charbonnages de france qui aujourd'hui
s'appelle gazelle et qui a été aussi et
en france d'un certain nombre
d'installations au charbon dans dans la
biomasse
donc ils ont construit des capacités de
production mais le problème on y
reviendra sans doute c'est que pour
l'instant on leur ferme
la voix pour pouvoir investir dans
certains domaines alors oui ils sont
aussi des fournisseurs
oui c'est ça ils vendent des abonnements
alors ils vendent aussi bien dans
l'électricité comme dans le gaz
des quantités croissantes d'électricité
et on c'est vrai que plus de cent mille
clients quittent df chaque mois pour
aller à la concurrence on peut penser
que ce sont des masochistes et puis
aucun intérêt mais on peut aussi penser
que finalement le choix ça du bruit et
qu'ils sont capables d'attirer un
certain nombre de clients et je dirais
pas seulement dans les clients
résidentiels je dirais aussi pour
beaucoup de clients industriels qui ont
l'habitude d'examiner attentivement
non seulement la facture mais l'ensemble
des services pour leurs offres
on y reviendra anne debrégeas ce vous
vous êtes chercheuse à edf recherche et
développement vous êtes membre du
syndicat sud énergie alors vous les
voyez comment vous ces producteurs
indépendants comment voyez vous la
concurrence
oui bah comme comme disait marc boudier
il faut distinguer deux choses dans la
privatisation du secteur électrique
il ya là le fait qu'ils aient des
investissements des investisseurs privés
sont arrivés dans le parc de production
mais là on ne peut pas parler de
concurrence c'est à dire que une fois
que les moyens de production sont
construits forcément ils vont ils vont
avoir des débouchés ils sont sûrs
d'écouler leur production
c'est un monopole naturel le secteur
électrique aussi bien les réseaux que la
production c'est à dire qu'on va pas
s'amuser à construire plus de réseau
qu'il n'en faut on va pas dupliquer les
réseaux et de la même manière on ne va
pas construire plus de moyens de
production qui n'en faut parce que ce ne
sont que des coûts fixes des
investissements de long terme et donc ça
serait une gabegie
donc on fait rentrer
investisseurs privés par des délégations
de service public comme sur les
autoroutes par exemple dans ta question
qui se pose derrière c'est est ce que ça
coûte plus cher au moins cher d'avoir
recours à des investisseurs privés ou à
des investisseurs publics on sent
pourriez revenir et nous on peut vous
dire que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
d'avoir recours à l'investissement
investissements privés parce que encore
une fois c'est un investissement très
long terme dans lequel les coûts
financiers jouent un rôle très important
et puis après il ya la partie en
concurrence est en fait la partie en
concurrence elle est limitée à ce qu'on
appelle la fourniture donc là il ya un
marché et les fournisseurs achètent sur
le marché et revendre et je pense que
c'est la bonne question vous avez posé
c'est à quoi sert cette fourniture c'est
ça n'existait pas du temps du monopole
il y avait un seul opérateur edf qui
produisait et puis qui transmettait
directement via les réseaux
l'électricité aux usagers
c'est vraiment un secteur particulier
l'électricité on n'a pas besoin d'un
détaillant qu'il irait acheter et puis
livrés aux clients
peut-être choisi choisir son produit au
départ et puis livrés aux clients dans
le produit il est de même pour tout le
monde
est un fournisseur ne touche à rien ça
s'est transmis directement
donc on a une activité qui s'est ajoutée
dans lequel il là il ya une cinquantaine
de fournisseurs aujourd'hui et on se
concentre là dessus sur la concurrence
alors on peut quand même se demander
pourquoi une activité qui aujourd'hui
représente à peu près 4 % des coûts
totaux du système qui n'existait pas
avant
peut apporter quelque chose aux clients
et évidemment ça ne sont seulement ça ça
augmente a introduit une complexité
énorme parce que pour que sept
fournisseurs existe il a fallu mettre en
place un marché pour leur permettre de
se fournir un marché qui est extrêmement
volatile il a fallu ben dupliquer tous
les systèmes d'information dupliquer les
équipes qui faisaient par exemple la
prévision de consommation
il a fallu développer des équipes
commerciales de démarchage de marchetti
des équipes de traders mettent en place
tous les opérateurs de bourse
tout ça ça un surcoût et en plus de ça
ça fragilise le système ça le rend
beaucoup plus compliqué comme ça un
système qui est déjà ultra complexe
puisqu'il faut à chaque instant
équilibré production et consommation
salle fragilise et on voit déjà des
problèmes à paraître de type coupure qui
sont dénoncés notamment
notamment parlé par les gestionnaires de
réseau entre l'association des
gestionnaires de réseaux et idy qui voit
apparaître des problèmes de stabilité
sur le réseau lié directement liée au
marché alors ben on est on est on a
commencé le débat
marc boudier donc est ce que les
producteurs indépendants sont
responsables et de l'augmentation des
prix les prix ont explosé depuis depuis
est ce que c'est de la faute des
producteurs indépendants si on augmente
aussi le le tarif qui lui est régulé
justement c'est pour leur donner un peu
de grain à moudre
et puis est-ce qu'ils sont responsables
aussi des coupures d'électricité il
semble de plus en plus en plus
nombreuses pour faire pour faire bonne
mesure non il serait peu responsable de
tout ce qui irait pas quoi non je
voudrais quand même dire un que la
france n est pas le seul pays en europe
ou dans le monde et dire que partout en
europe on a un système ou au contraire
on a de multiples acteurs alors c'est
peut-être plus compliqué mais ça offre
aussi les capacités de choix et tant
mieux et où on a un rôle spécifique pour
chacun le le transporteur en français
rte mais évidemment des transporteurs
dans tous les pays
quel que soit leur statut public ou
privé d'ailleurs mais qui ont ce rôle de
transport déquilibre du système il ya le
distributeur en france on en est un qui
couvrent 95 % du territoire
en allemagne on en a neuf cents c'est
peut-être un peu compliqué aussi c'est
sûr mais en tout cas c'est un système
qui est différent et puis le fournisseur
il a un rôle autonome c'est celui qui va
être là pour écouter les besoins du
client les déterminer savoir comment
aussi faire des économies parce que
c'est pas simplement le tarif de
l'électricité qui compte c'est celle à
la note finale
et d'ailleurs si la fourniture n'a
aucune importance dans le projet recul
ce qui semble faire peur c'est qu'on
isole la partie commerciale si elle n'a
pas d'importance et bien je pense que du
coup ce serait pas forcément un problème
je ne crois pas que ce soit le cas
alors sur la responsabilité ça c'est une
question un peu d'actualité
on en arrive à la paradoxe c'est que je
comprends très bien qu'on puisse dire en
france en particulier quand de la
situation quasi monopolistique d'edf
dans la production les la concurrence
n'a pas réussi à faire baisser
considérablement les coûts bon il ya des
offres qui sont moins chers notamment
pour pôle résidentiel aussi pour un
certain nombre de clients industriels
mais c'est vrai que de là à dire que
c'est la concurrence qui a fait monter
les coûts je crois que il faut tout de
même avoir en perspective
en quoi consiste le prix de
l'électricité le bouquet final
et bien évidemment il ya le prix de
l'énergie mais il ya surtout deux autres
composantes qui sont les taxes et qui
sont évidemment le coût d'acheminement
c'est à dire le transport la
distribution
c'est qu'est ce qui a fait augmenter
considérablement les prix de
l'électricité pas qu'en france
là aussi en europe c'est le
développement des taxes en france a été
la cspe maintenance ntic et feu qui
représente 30% de la facture beaucoup
plus que ce qui se passait auparavant et
ces taxes elles ont été augmentées pour
pouvoir notamment financer l'adaptation
du système le développement du
renouvelable la solidarité avec les pays
avec les ans entre les territoires enfin
c'est une une composante qui a explosé
c'est elle et exploser donc peut-être
que la concurrence a réussi à peut-être
freiné certains aspects de développement
de marques commerciales de commerciaux à
a poussé aussi edf à se rénover à faire
attention à ces coups à faire aussi
preuve d'innovation je trouve que c'est
très bien d'avoir de la concurrence
aussi prenez est-ce que vous avez la
même vision et de bajaj
non bien sûr que non sur l'augmentation
des prix donc là
la facture moyenne des usagers la dcri
l'électricité ont augmenté de 60 %
depuis 2006 à ses reprises s'est montrée
par l'insee et marc boudier a raison ce
n'est pas tout à mettre sur le compte de
la libéralisation loin de là
effectivement il a fallu financer dé
nouveaux des nouvelles nouveaux moyens
de production il a fallu de financer la
rénovation des réseaux
la question c'est est-ce que la
libéralisation donc l'ouverture de la
mise en concurrence a poussé à la hausse
ou à la baisse les prix et ça les choses
sont claires ça a poussé ça a contribué
à ces augmentations de prix si on
revient à comment et effet les prix
auparavant tout le monde avait un tarif
qu'on appelle le tarifs réglementés de
vente donc un tarif unique alors pour
les pour les particuliers pour les
clients particuliers c'est le tarif bleu
que je pense tout le monde connaît et
tout le monde donc avaient une grille
tarifaire simple est arrivée la
concurrence avec des offres de marché
spécifique différent du tarif réglementé
comme donc d'abord pour les entreprises
pour les entreprises une grande partie
d'entre elles ont opté pour ses offres
de marché qui était indexée sur les prix
de marché d'électricité donc encore une
fois très volatile les prix de marché se
sont envolés et les entreprises ont dit
ah bah nous on voudrait quand même
revenir aux tarifs réglementés de vente
est ce que ça serait pas possible donc
on a remis un tarif provisoire on
appelait le tartam est la plupart des
entreprises sont revenus à ce talent
mais on leur a dit il ya eu des actions
devant devant l'union européenne et il
ya eu une décision qui était dire ces
tarifs seront supprimés pour les
entreprises donc on les a en fait forcé
à venir tout sur les offres de marché
alors qu'une partie d'entre elles vous
le voulez rester aux tarifs
ces tarifs réglementés sont restés pour
les clients particuliers
pour l'instant on ne sait pas combien de
temps ça va durer mais il ya eu un
changement de mode de calcul de ces
tarifs réglementés de vente c'est à dire
que jusqu'à maintenant il était calculé
pour que tout le monde paye pareil et
puis pour qu'à la fin ça couvre
l'ensemble des coûts du système
électrique
et là l'objectif de ces tarifs
réglementés de vente a changé en 2015
s'est inscrit tout le monde peut aller
regarder dans les textes
l'objectif maintenant c'est un objectif
qu'on appelle de comté stabilité et qui
dit qu' il faut que ce tarifs
réglementés de vente soient suffisamment
élevés
permettre à des fournisseurs concurrents
d'edf de faire des offres moins cher que
le tarif alors même l'autorité de la
concurrence a dit mme enfin c'est quand
même pas possible on n'a jamais vu ça
dans aucun autre secteur ça veut dire
qu'on fait du tarifs réglementés de
vente un prix maximum pour permettre à
n'importe quel fournisseur y compris les
moins performants d'utiliser cette ce
tarif est donc pour faire ça on a chaud
on a on a un des ondes à changer le mode
de calcul des tarifs réglementés de
vente qui maintenant reflète la manière
dont se fournissent ses fournisseurs
alternatifs qui n'ont pas de moyens de
production
donc c'est à dire qu' une partie est au
prix régulés du nucléaire d'accès au
nucléaire et sur lequel on va revenir je
pense et une partie est au président et
au prix de marché et comme le prix de
marché a augmenté et bien les dernières
ou pour garder sa sur les dernières
hausses de tarifs réglementés de vente
qui ont eu lieu celle de 2019 ya quand
même eu une augmentation de près de 8%
il ya eu encore 4 % l'année dernière et
là on vient de nous annoncer une
nouvelle hausse
quand on regarde les décisions de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
sur la raison l'augmentation de ses
tarifs
ce ne sont pas les augmentations de
coûts d'edf c'est l'augmentation des
prix de marché donc c'est directement
lié aux prix de marché mais de toute
façon il peut pas en être autrement
le encore une fois le l'ouverture à la
concurrence n'a fait que rajouter des
coûts donc j'ai dit à des coûts
démarchage
enfin je veux bien qu'on essaye de
gagner un peu de performance sur tel ou
tel point enfin quand on rajoute des
équipes commerciales des démarchages
tout le monde a vu que ces démarches est
extrêmement fréquent il faut bien payer
les gens quand on duplique tous les
systèmes d'information tous les systèmes
de facturation
quand on augmente énormément les
services juridiques parce que avant tout
les tous les échanges entre les digues
les moyens de production le réseau
c'était des échanges inter entreprises
informelles maintenant ça devient tout
contractualiser et surtout quand on
augmente à nouveau et les coûts
financiers
mais forcément il va falloir que
quelqu'un de paix mais au bout du compte
est ce quelqu'un c'est forcément l'usagé
qui maintenant est venu clients juste
sur les coûts sur les coûts financiers
je voudrais quand même dire que le 6 le
système enfin le donc là on part de la
part énergie en parle de la reproduction
pour le pour l'instant la partie réseau
allait encore
et encore son monopole public donc la
partie énergie pour le nuc donc il ya
une énergie d'avenir ça va être dur
renouvelables et ça va être peut-être du
nucléaire on verra le renouvelable c'est
100% de coûts fixes et essentiellement
des investissements sur 25 à 30 ans et
le nucléaire c'est 80 à 90% de coûts
fixes donc pas du tout adapté un marché
sur des échéances la de 60 ans donc
c'est comme quand vous achetez une
maison quand on prend un sens et des
investissements sur le très long terme
comme ça
selon le taux le taux selon lequel on
peut on va rémunérer son capital donc le
taux d'intérêt si on fait des emprunts
bancaires ou taux de rémunération des
actionnaires privés va être déterminant
dans le coût total de production
et quand je dis déterminant c'est pour
le nucléaire si on se fait rémunérer à
2% est aujourd'hui l'état français peut
emprunter à 0 5% sur 50 ans donc 2 % ça
peut être un tout public ou si on se
fait rémunérer à 9% ce qui est ce que
demandent généralement les marchés ça
conduit à doubler le coût de production
finale c'est pas moi qui me fais moi
j'ai fait des calculs met en garde la
cour des comptes anglais sur hinkley
point elle écrit dans une étude de 2010
est donc l'époque la centrale nucléaire
anglaise est dit si on a un taux de
rentabilité exigée des investissements à
2 % on est à 30 euros du mégawattheures
si on passe à 9%
on passe à 100 euros du mégawattheure et
c'est documenté par tous et documentée
par l' agence internationale de
l'énergie dont la cd surcoût énorme et
qui dit sur coup dit enfin je pense pas
que cette fois les fournisseurs qui
pioche dans le monde leur poche pour
payer donc à la fin ça va se retrouver
sur la facture des clients
alors marc boudier en croit le constate
et c'est normal premièrement il faut il
faut je crois distinguer certain nombre
de choses le prix du marché c'est vrai
que c'est un prix qui évoluent et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que il y a en france
a dans beaucoup de pays européens mais
encore en france le maintien des tarifs
réglementés de vente dont bénéficie
aussi des f1 semaine
et il a été fait selon une formule du
temps qu'il vend des cookies permet de
tenir compte des coûts et n'oblige pas
non plus edf à vendre à perte
on est resté très longtemps auparavant
dans un schéma où le prix l'électricité
c'est un prix politique et même si
objectivement il aurait dû évoluer et
bien pour des raisons politiques on le
maintenaient où on essayait de maintenir
artificiellement bas ce qui était pas
bon non plus pour edf et pour sa
capacité d'investir on reviendra sur
l'état dramatique un d'ailleurs des
finances d'edf aujourd'hui qui explique
qu'ils aient ce chef de ce projet une
notamment donc ce prix du marché les
volumes je signale que d'ailleurs le
prix du marché il tout aussi évolué à la
baisse
on va en reparler quand on parlera tout
à l'heure de la reine
il y a des moments où il est nettement
plus bas que l'autre référence qui sert
à faire calculer les les prix des tarifs
réglementés c'est-à-dire la reine le
prix du nucléaire régulier donc faut pas
oublier que marcher mais il est volatil
et pitt
autre remarque toujours pour faire une
comparaison internationale c'est
toujours bon d'avoir en tête ce qui se
passe en allemagne le prix final pour le
consommateur individuel il est plus
élevé qu'en france parce que le prix du
marché serait plus fort qu'en france non
non il est structurellement est assez
nettement inférieur à ce qu'il est en
france sur la part énergie avec la
production qui est fait est assurée
essentiellement par edf
et qu'est ce qui explique cette
différence de prix c'est qu'en allemagne
on a développé considérablement les
renouvelables et que ça a conduit a
effectivement des subventions des taxes
qui se retrouvent dans dans le prix
final
donc c'est un système qui est différent
mais n'oublions pas que
le prix du marché encore une fois il
peut évoluer à la hausse comme à la
baisse
alors question suivante se ce projet
hercules dont on nous parle beaucoup
alors il est très technique il va
falloir être très clair et pour moi et
pour ceux qui nous regardent
qu'est ce qui va se passer est ce qu'on
démantèle eu des des f
on va en privatiser une partie à la
demande de bruxelles
laquelle est ce que tout ça c'est bon
pour edf
est-ce que c'est mauvais pour edf est ce
que c'est bon pour les consommateurs ou
est-ce que c'est mauvais pour les
consommateurs d'électricité
anne debrégeas alors le principe de
d'hercule pour faire simple c'est
qu'effectivement on part d'une situation
qui n'est pas bonne du tout comme l'a
dit marc bouvier s'est pas tenable edf
est dans une situation financière
catastrophique au passage est dans une
situation financière catastrophique
depuis l'ouverture des marchés avant
elle était dans une situation tout à
fait saine et donc on a une entreprise
qui pour l'instant vend à perte une
partie de son nucléaire et puis
n'arrivent pas à investir on a un patron
d'edf qui nous dit pour la première fois
de notre histoire on a su construire
on a su électrifier la france on a su
construire un parc hydraulique un parc
thermique un parc nucléaire aujourd'hui
on n'a plus les moyens d'investir dans
ce qu'il faudrait donc partant de ce
constat d'une situation qui ne convient
pas ce que ce que propose le projet et
recule donc c'est l'essai de séparer en
trois pôles enfin de ce qu'on en sait
aujourd'hui edf deux pôles publics donc
un premier pôle public nucléaire dans
lequel il y aurait toute la production
nucléaire et a priori aussi la
production thermique un deuxième pôle
qui lui aussi sera public dans lequel il
y aurait la production hydraulique
enfin les concessions hydrauliques donc
on reconnaît au passage que toute cette
production là est complètement inadapté
aux marchés et puis un troisième pôle
qui lui serait plus largement ouvert aux
capitaux privés donc partiellement
privatisée qu'on appelle le pôle vert et
dans lequel on l'est on met les autres
activités d'edf c'est à dire en
particulier
donc la partie commerciale on l'a dit
les commerciaux d'edf qui donc
achèteront leur production dans les
mêmes conditions que les autres
fournisseurs via un marché ou via un
mécanisme avait des airs producteurs on
aura les énergies renouvelables d'edf on
aura le réseau de distribution de
manière complètement incompréhensible
parce que par contre la partie réseau de
transport donc de rte elle se retrouvera
dans le pô le public
et puis on aurait aussi des activités
internationales d'edf peut-être les
systèmes insulaires face qui skie ce qui
reste de deux activités
donc nous le problème que ça nous pose
c'est que une fois de plus on continue
dans cette mise en concurrence du
secteur électrique qui est impossible
qui est intrinsèquement impossible parce
qu'encore une fois quand on a une
industrie de réseaux où tous les coûts
sont fixes c'est complètement inadapté
aux marchés on aurait pu revenir sur les
prix de marché qui effectivement font
n'importe quoi et son reflet tu évolues
au pot au gré des cours mondiaux du gaz
et du charbon alors que l'électricité
n'est quasiment pas produite à partir de
gaz et de charbon
enfin c'est une autre histoire donc au
lieu de faire un bilan de 20 ans
libéralisation qui franchement un bilan
un défendre à personne nous nous mais un
seul argument pour nous dire ce qu'il
enlève on a dit au début ça allait faire
baisser les prix
plus personne n'ose dire ça maintenant
on nous dit que ça crée l'innovation
quand on entend les associations de
consommateurs qui disent la seule
innovation que nous on voit c'est les
démarchages agressifs et frauduleux ça
c'est le jeu de je cite une association
de consommateurs bon bout d'un moment il
faut s'arrêter il faut regarder il faut
se dire que on est dans une situation
d'urgence climatique on a des
investissements énormes affaires dans le
secteur électrique qui est qui est un
des piliers de la transition énergétique
puisqu'il va falloir se passer de
pétrole et de gaz donc on va avoir tout
le parc de production dans les
prochaines décennies a remplacé plus le
réseau a énormément adapté pour intégrer
les énergies renouvelables on est dans
un état de désorganisation avec une
entreprise qui va mal plus personne qui
peut investir avec des prix de marché
est on en train de une fois de plus
essayer de réparer un système qui va de
mal en pire chaque fois on est obligé de
rajouter des six des mécanismes qui ne
fonctionne pas et nous ont dit non ça
suffit on arrête ça
il ya une urgence on peut démontrer on a
tout développer des argumentations pour
dire la façon la plus efficace et la
moins coûteuse pour gérer le système
électrique c'est un système public
on a une opposition enfin au des
soutiens dans le monde politique à
droite comme à gauche pour dire nous on
comprends pas quel est l'argument est le
seul argument fait que donner ses 20 ans
et c'est l'europe qui nous impose enfin
c'est quand même pas acceptable donc
arrêtons là ne faisons pas un pas de
plus en essayant de réparer un mécanisme
absurde qu'on appelle la reine peut-être
qu'on y reviendra par un autre mécanisme
tout aussi absurde ya qu une seule
solution qui fonctionnera c'est un
système régulé on a besoin de
planification on a besoin
d'investissements et ça c'est public qui
peut le faire il ya une minute avant la
pause marc boudier donc je vous donnerai
la parole après la pause
oui je l'autre comme non mais quel
honneur ont fait la concurrence y
compris d'être responsable de toutes les
difficultés d'edf même c'est pas la
concurrence en france qui a fait que le
projet de flamanville est passé d'un
coût de 3 3 milliards d'euros estimés
avec une mise en service en 2012 à un
coût de 10 9 milliards avec une mise en
service en 2024
donc les un certain nombre des
difficultés de l'endettement d'edf
les très grands projets qu'il compte
faire y compris dans des pays étrangers
comme comme l'angleterre
1 le projet de nucléaire din clé polt
tout ça ça contribue un endettement
massif
et pendant ce temps là tout en ayant la
volonté de continuer à avoir une
expansion internationale en étant
présent en italie et ailleurs
il faudrait qu edf garde absolument
toutes ses activités et le modèle de bon
fonctionnement
c'est l'entreprise monopolistique unique
avec l'état dont on sait que il est dans
tous les domaines le meilleur
actionnaire potentiel
quand vous dites nam que
l'hydroélectricité ça j'arrête marché
mes marques je vous arrête on fait la
pause leur donne la parole juste après
[Musique]
les prévisions de croissance pour
l'année 2000 21 ans n'ont jamais été
aussi incertaine bien sûr que vous
pouvez avoir 6% à ce moment là était sur
la table comme le font les états unis
2000 milliards et puis vous aurez de la
croissance simplement il faudra les
rembourser un jour une fois qu'on sera
dans la période est membre
l'atterrissage en douceur à ce moment là
il y aura un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui commenceront à tomber
c'est là que l'on pourra faire l'état
des dégâts
je vous rappelle que ça n'est pas le
virus qui tue l'économie ce sont les
mesures qu'on a appliqué pour bloquer
l'économie
objectivement personne ne sait ce que
sera la croissance de la france mais
aussi de la plupart des pays européens
on peut simuler une croissance mais une
vraie croissance qui repose sur des
fondamentaux solides
vous n'êtes pas prêt de la voir
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata pas par an pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça mais il faut
que leur qu'istres groove la musique
c'est la traduction la plus poétique de
la vie si vous mettez pas la vie des
évidemment on s'embête il faut sortir
les notes de leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur l'avenir d'edf
avec marc boudier qui est l'ancien
directeur europe du groupe edf passer à
la concurrence il est aujourd'hui
président de la fieec l'association des
producteurs de gaz et d'électricité
indépendant et anne debrégeas ce qui est
chercheuse à edf recherche et
développement et membre du syndicat sud
énergie jourdan prend la parole marc
c'est à vous absolument alors je suis en
train de dire que effectivement quand on
dit que l'hydroélectricité par exemple
ça n'est pas possible de comptes de
penser que ça va entrer dans le marché
c'est exactement le contraire qui se
passe dans tous les pays nordiques par
exemple le nord foule
c'est un marché qui est essentiellement
fait d'eux des prix de
l'hydroélectricité qui varient mais et
qui se situe à des niveaux de
compétitivité qui sont très bons et dont
les citoyens bénéficient alors en ce qui
concernait recule effectivement on
partons de la situation d'edf un plus de
40 milliards d'endettement un certain
nombre d'investissements massifs à
prévoir par exemple que pour moderniser
et sécuriser le parc nucléaire
on peut parler de 50 milliards 55
milliards certains vont jusqu'à 90
milliards
les projets anglais c'est aussi des
dizaines de milliards
disons que on peut difficilement
concevoir que on va pouvoir aller de
l'avant sans réfléchir à un
assainissement de la situation et à
trouver les financements
alors le financement on s'appelle très
simplement le contribuable français font
rares nationalisons et c'est le
contribuable qui va contribuer à
l'acquittement des générations futures
en rajoutant à la dette en question mais
on peut aussi penser qu'un certain
nombre d'activités sont susceptibles
même si elles restent majoritairement
public d'accueillir du capital qui sera
pas forcément d'ailleurs privé on parle
toujours de privatisation
et là je vais être très clair vous avez
une filiale d'edf qui s'appelle rte
c'est elle qui s'occupe du transport
d'électricité c'est à dire donc deux des
grandes quantités d'électricité poids de
5 est bien bien que filiale d'edf
elle est gérée de façon complètement
indépendante et à la satisfaction de
tous parce que c'est elle qui a la
responsabilité de l'equilibre le système
ce n'est pas edf en tant que tel c'est
rte qui a cette responsabilité d'
équilibre eh bien on a ouvert il n'y a
pas si longtemps le capital à hauteur de
42% pas je ne sais quel requin mais à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations bon
bah c'est un moyen pour rte de pouvoir
financer ses investissements aussi
peut-être que demain ça peut être le cas
pour kennedy ce qui fait de la
distribution
il est important qu'ils gardent une
certaine neutralité même s'ils restent
filiale d'edf
et quant aux activités concurrentielles
pour qu'elle soit concurrentiel et que
chacun soit placé sur un pied d'égalité
il ya aucune raison que edf commerces
puissent pouvoir utiliser des positions
qui serait celle de la production pour
pouvoir faire disons la loi sur l'eau
sur le plan commercial ou offrir des
offres qui seraient pas conformes aux
bonnes règles de concurrence
on reviendra sur le nom sans croiser etc
on reviendra sur le projet recul mais je
voudrais vous demander pourquoi on a
failli avoir ce ce black out le 8
janvier dernier des millions d'européens
ont failli être plongés dans le noir et
dans le froid en plein hiver avec ça
s'est joué à un cheveu
on nous dit que ça va certainement se
reproduire on nous annonce d'ailleurs
des pénuries des coupures d'électricité
des pénuries d'électricité en 2021 ça
paraît absolument dingue alors qu'est ce
qui se passe pourquoi en est on arrivé
là est ce que c'est la faute aux
énergies renouvelables qui comme vous
c'est le solaire l'éolien
ces deux sont des énergies
intermittentes
aléatoire qu'on ne peut pas stocker est
ce que c'est de la démagogie écologiste
qui veut que on soit voué au
rationnement
ou à la pénurie non je crois qu'il faut
enfin on en est quand même pas au
rationnement et la pénurie c'est vrai
qu'on partait d'une situation de
surproduction en europe et qu' il va
falloir s'habituer à faire avec moins de
surproduction il va falloir diminuer
notre consommation d'énergie à la
stratégie nationale bas carbone fatou
toutes les hypothèses qui conduisent à
la neutralité carbone en 2050 montrent
qu'il faut diviser par deux la
consommation d'énergie pas spécialement
d'électricité puisque par ailleurs
certains usages vont enfin il va falloir
remplacer le pétrole et gaz et on va le
remplacer en partie par par
l'électricité
donc il ya des difficultés effectivement
d'équilibrage pour ça que système
électrique est si compliqué c'est que ça
ce stock presque pas on va dire enfin de
manière très très difficile et il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient égalité parfaite à
chaque instant sur l'ensemble du réseau
européen
sinon on peut aller très vite au black
out mais les gestionnaires de réseau
sont quand même là pour pour veiller à
ce qu'ils savent pas ce que ça n'arrive
pas et quand il ya un déséquilibre pour
isoler le problème et faire des coupures
ciblées
donc il va falloir trouver des moyens de
faire en sorte d'intégrer ces énergies
intermittentes que sont le solaire et
l'éolien qui ne produisent pas à chaque
instant alors là il ya des scénarios qui
sont à l'étude qui notamment rt1
justement fait ces scénarios rte grâce à
sa situation de monopole a encore une
démarche assez public là dedans pour
étudier comment on pourrait faire alors
une solution s'est gardé de nucléaire
qui peut moduler ce qu'on appelle
moduler et qui est une énergie pilotable
kids on peut intervenir au moment où on
en a besoin
et puis il ya d'autres solutions qui
sont aussi sur la table est qui et qui
seront plus détaillée dans les mois qui
viennent par exemple avoir recours à la
production d'hydrogène pur comme moyen
de stock avoir recours au biogaz à la
biomasse avoir recourt aussi à des
moyens de stockage ce type
hydro hydroélectricité donc des sous
l'appel des stades des stations de
pompage
donc voilà il ya plusieurs manières de
faire c'est vrai que c'est une
difficulté mais
dans tous les cas je pense qu'on peut
faire sans arriver au black out c'est
vrai qu'on va être en situation moins
confortable qu'avant et c'est pour ça
aussi parce qu'on est devant un défi
énorme ou à la fois il faut augmenter
les usages de l'électricité et peut-être
se passer du nucléaire s'il ya une
décision qui est prise dans ce sens là
il va falloir utiliser tous les
potentiels qu'on a partout utiliser
l'éolien offshore l'éolien offshore
tout un tout un tas de par d'autres vous
interrompre mes dix économistes je crois
que c'est l'été dernier disait que si
tous les pays développés en 1973 avait
fait le choix du tout nucléaire qui a
été fait par carme espère à l'époque le
premier ministre de georges pompidou
si tous les pays développés avaient fait
le même choix il y aurait pas eu de
réchauffement climatique
et là vous êtes en train de m'expliquer
que pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique on va choisir de se passer du
nucléaire qui est la seule énergie
un concert qui dont les émissions de co2
sont pas plus haute que seuls des
énergies renouvelables à la différence
près que nucléaire ça marche tout le
temps et pas les énergies renouvelables
donc comment se passer du nucléaire
aujourd'hui c'est pour rouvrir le charbo
c'est c'est quoi le plan annan ancien
nom n'ont sûrement pas non mais c'est
sûr que c'est sûr qu effectivement si
s'il n'y avait pas eu de deux moyens
thermiques développée qu'on avait fait
le choix du nucléaire on aurait pas de
problème de réchauffement climatique on
aura peut-être eu d'autres problèmes et
en tout cas est hissé hors de question
de continuer à avoir des énergies
fossiles ça il faut absolument s'en
passer et de manière très urgente après
sur la question du nucléaire on a sur la
table des scénarios qui ont été mis des
scénarios sans énergie fossile donc sans
émission qui atteignent la neutralité
carbone et qui se passe du nucléaire il
y as derrière des points technologiques
qui sont un peu d'innovation quoi qui va
sur lequel il va falloir il va falloir
mener des études donc aujourd'hui il ya
des scénarios qui sont sur la table plus
tôt par par des associations ou par
l'ademe il ya un scénario qui vient de
sortir des grandes lignes d'un scénario
qui viennent sorte de sortir
rte enfin en alliance entre rte et
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie aie
encore une fois il ya des scénarios très
détaillé qui vont sortir
au printemps ou à l'automne prochain par
rte qui étudient des options avec 50% de
nucléaire et des options 100 %
renouvelable n'est qu'ils atteignent
aussi la neutralité carbone
donc il ya des solutions mais est-ce que
c'est mieux que que le nucléaire ça on
verra quand on aura les scénarios et à
chacun de juger
en fait il n'ya pas de n'y a pas
d'énergie eau miraculeuse et sans risque
et sans effet marc boudier oui alors sur
sur les causes de black out
elles peuvent être diverses il ya eu il
ya quelques années c'est c'est des
arbres qui sont tombés sur des lignes à
haute tension entre la la suisse et
l'italie qui ont failli mettre en l'air
l'ensemble du système européen
il ya eu un autre moment plus tard ou
c'est un bateau qui à hambourg a
endommagé un centre d'installation donc
vous pouvez avoir une certaine fragilité
du système indépendamment des
renouvelables
et d'ailleurs c'est la preuve que il est
extrêmement compliquée en matière
énergétique de raisonner uniquement à
l'échelle nationale on est sur un
ensemble interconnectés et il faut qu'il
y ait justement un jeu qui soit jouée
par tous et que les engagements
européens que nous avons soient tenus
par ailleurs en ce concerne le nucléaire
moi je pense que c'est un atout
considérable pour la france 1 à l'ailé
les français ont payé ce parc et se
retrouvent se sont bien trouvés pour les
raisons qu'on connaît y compris
environnementale mais il faut maintenant
savoir quelles seront les solutions
d'avenir
la solution d'avenir c'est effectivement
de développer des renouvelables aussi
est également d'espérer avec les progrès
techniques que l'on va faire que non
seulement on aura une baisse
considérable de coûts de ces
renouvelables ce qui aujourd'hui le cas
c'est le solaire l'éolien deviennent
compétitifs quand on compare notamment
au nouveau nucléaire mais on va pouvoir
essayer de développer aussi le stockage
qui sait qu'on pourra
à un coût si le coût devient acceptable
pouvoir faire face justement à cette
intermittence
il ya un point sur lequel moi je pense
qu'on sous estime le problème c'est que
on est bien dans une phase de transition
et à la situation actuelle et on va pas
changer du jour au lendemain fois sur le
le poids du nucléaire ou ou sur d'autres
sujets la capacité de stockage avec
renouvelables et donc il ya
impérativement à maintenir pour la
sécurité du système
un certain nombre d'activités thermique
elles vont pas très vont pas fonctionné
en base tous les jours de l'année ça va
pas produire beaucoup de co2 si vous
prenez ça sur l'année mais par contre il
ya des moments elles seront complètement
indispensable et l'autre jour il ya eu
une alerte savez sur les réseaux en
france et où on pensait qu'on allait
pouvoir faire aussi de l'effacement
parce qu'il ya toutes les solutions
également qui consiste à travailler non
pas seulement sur la production mais sur
la demande
eh bien on s'est aperçu que ce jour là
il faisait très froid
le nucléaire produit est l'essentiel
l'hydraulique aussi le thermique
notamment le gaz
il y avait même le charbon et l'éolien
c'est un jour très froid avait sans vent
qui peut vendre au contraire par moments
des capacités très importante était
complètement absents bon donc ça veut
dire qu'effectivement il faut à mon avis
dans l'intérêt du système ne pas
certainement projeter des productions
fossiles comme comme futur mais faire
attention de ne pas hypothéquer le
présent aujourd'hui anne debrégeas ce
sachant que l'éolien c'est quand même
quelque chose auquel on ne pense pas
toujours
outre le fait que c'est très polluants
notamment dans la mer parce qu'il faut
le coulé dans le béton
en fait ça fait du bruit et de la
lumière enfin on sait tout ça mais il en
faudrait énormément enfin je vu des
calculs de gens très pointu qui disait
que pour que avec un vent de 25 km/heure
permanent si on voulait faire
fonctionner le métro et le rer parisien
avec des éoliennes il faudrait quatre
cent cinquante éoliennes pour se
représenter ce que c'est 450 éoliennes
le paysage la cc de la destruction du
paysage qui est qui et quand même sans
précédent est ce que vous en pensez and
the boys love mais on va pas fort c'est
sûr qu'on va pas faire tout avec avec
des éoliennes
encore une fois il ya des scénarios qui
existent et qui sont dites enfin les
spéciaux qui vont être présentés ils
analyseront aussi l'impact
environnemental voilà mais c'est sûr
qu'on n'aura pas encore une fois
d'énergie qui sera qui n'aura pas
d'impact sur sur les paysages sur qui ne
produiront pas de déchets qui ne
produiront pas des risques d'accident ou
qui seront neutres sans climat donc il
va ou qui ne poseront pas des problèmes
d'accès à l'eau par exemple ou d'accès à
des ressources rares donc il va falloir
faire des choix et c'est pour ça
justement qu'il faut alors effectivement
salamagne européenne à tout le réseau
est interconnecté ne me dis pas qu'il
faut se déconnecter
de l'europe on dit juste qu'il faut pas
gérer sa part un marché mais on voit
bien que c'est tellement compliqué il
faut garantir à chaque heure cet
équilibre alors que effectivement on a
des difficultés de stockage que ça
demande une planification ultra fine et
une utilisation au mieux des ressources
qu'on a sachant que toutes ont un impact
social écologique environnementale et
donc c'est forcément un choix collectif
qui doit aboutir à ça on fait pas le
choix de développer dans son poing tels
moyens de production au talon est et
c'est pour ça aussi ça veut pas de la
concurrence c'est planifié
collectivement on va décider de faire le
choix d'aller soit de se passer du
nucléaire soit pas s'en passer et donc
de développer à fond dès l'éolien aussi
en mer il ya beaucoup d'aidé des
audiences offshore avec aussi des
contraintes l'éolien sur terre
l'hydroélectricité qui peut encore être
développé un peu et puis une autre et
puis le recours à la biomasse aussi
sachant que ça pose d'autres problèmes
parce qu'il ya des conflits d'usagé avec
l'agriculture par exemple et on va être
obligé de faire des choix qui nous
embarque tous et donc ils doivent être
des choix forcément collectif
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un mot
de la géothermie est bien un projet à
strasbourg qui semble être arrêté
maintenant on en avait un qui était
devenue la panacée la géothermie puisse
aller ça semble ne plus l'être parce que
ça va poser des problèmes de je pense
qu'il ya eu des problèmes techniques
dans la manière dont ça a été fait et ça
fait des des tremblements de terre dans
la région dans tous les scénarios la
géothermie il n'apparaît pas comme un
moyen de production majeure ça reste ça
reste un petit moyens de production donc
là encore vous regarder au cas par cas
s'il ya des s'il ya des façons de faire
mais moi j'ai eu pas spécialiste de la
question
mais c'est en tout cas ça restera
forcément un moyen marginal cantonné
scénario ça paraît comme ça ma boudier
là c'était de la gc de la géothermie
profonde qui a effectivement provoquer
quelques problèmes sismique
mais vous avez dans toute une série de
villes y compris dans la région
parisienne dès chauffage urbain qui sont
alimentés par des puits de géothermie
avec de très bons résultats et à la fois
sur le plan économique et sur le plan
environnemental donc mais un as raison
c'est pas forcément quelque chose qui va
permettre massivement de produire de
l'électricité ou 2 ou 2 roues de ou de
l'énergie dans le pays mais ça peut être
très utile à un petit à petit tout petit
référence de coups puisqu'on parle
beaucoup de coups l'éolien offshore
le dernier appel d'offres qui était
d'ailleurs remporté par edf
on va croire qu'ils sont quand même
quelques moyens malgré leur situation un
peu difficile
c'est encore financiers de faire des
débats s'offrent à un peu plus de 40
euros par de mélo gâteurs je crois que
c'était 41 ou au bout de cet ordre là
bon le nucléaires amorties et df
estiment ses 42 euros par mégawattheure
la reine estiment qu'ils bradent aspect
là et il vient d'y avoir un appel
d'offres en espagne / du solaire ou
celui qui a gagné parce que comme
souvent c'est là c'est les appels
d'offres qui permettent de dégager les
meilleures offres et à à 30 euros par
mégawattheure je vous rappelle qu'il ya
quelques années le solaire il valait
cette fois le prix du nucléaire
donc il ya eu une évolution considérable
alors après vous avez raison ça peut pas
se construire n'importe où il peut il
faut s'y tient partage avec
l'agriculture il ya des formules de ce
fait mais il ya quand même un potentiel
de développement des renouvelables qui
est incontestable est là dessus
évidemment on peut compter sur des
alternatives aussi pour participer à cet
effort d'équipement et de production et
et on espère bien ça va être ouvert
aussi à l'hydroélectricité
alors pour conclure il nous reste sept
minutes attirer des capitaux pour pour
conclure quel avenir vous voyez alors
vous allez nous le résumé et pour edf et
pour l'électricité en france à debré
chasse on a bien compris
une pensée qu'il faut renationaliser et
que au fond ça doit ravir à ses voeux un
service public
un seul tarif tout le territoire il faut
faire ce serait plus économique et plus
efficace oui absolument alors quand on
quand on dit renationaliser il faut
évidemment apprendre des erreurs du
passé il faut quand j'ai dit quand je
dis que ça doit être public n'est pas
forcément tout centraliser on peut
réfléchir à des formes de
décentralisation en plus avec
l'apparition d'énergie décentralisée en
sachant qu'il ya une partie qui restera
centralisée il faut réfléchir un vrai
contrôle citoyen sur sur cet opérateur
public
bon c'est alors on peut l'appeler edf
edf a déjà été beaucoup transformé et
quand j'entends monsieur bédié qui dit
edf a beau jeu de dire que c'est la
concurrence mais ils n'arrivent pas à
produire flamanville et puis ils font
des activités internationales
importantes c'est vrai mais c'est lié là
aussi la libéralisation du secteur edf
s'est mis à avoir un objectif de grandes
de grands oligopoles comme il ya dans
toute l'europe avec un objectif de 50 %
du chiffre d'affaires allez à l'étranger
aux dépens du service public en france
ce qu'a reconnu ce qu'a déploré la
fédération des des régies l'aude et des
collectivités territoriales qui gèrent
les réseaux qui possède les réseaux de
distribution pardon pardon en dix ans
les investissements étrangers c'est de
l'argent qui a pas été mis dans les
réseaux à une certaine époque entier et
qui a produit une augmentation sensible
du nombre de coupures sur le réseau de
distribution
quant à flamanville effectivement on
peut se demander aussi pourquoi une
entreprise qui a su construire un parc
nucléaire entier sans parler du parc
hydroélectrique n'est plus capable
aujourd'hui de faire une centrale
nucléaire mais là encore et l'entreprise
s'est profondément transformé il ya des
chaînes de sous traitance à n'en plus
finir il ya six ans sous traitants
qu'interviennent sur flamanville des
niveaux qui jusqu'à cette fois 25
langues et ça se passe mal là encore
tirant son bilan mais ne disons pas que
c'est l'entreprise publique a fait ça
edf ne se comporte plus comme une
entreprise publique elle est régie par
les mêmes règles que les autres
entreprises en concurrence à dire
qu'elles doivent faire de la rentabilité
à court terme n a plus les moyens des
doivent respecter des ratios
d'endettement qui sont complètement
qui nous conviennent pas à des
entreprises peuvent investir sur 20 30
ou 60 ans et puis juste pour finir quand
comme si vous deviez dit il faut bien
que quelqu'un on pas demandé au
contribuable de payer des
investissements il faut avoir recours au
privé mais enfin à la fin qui va payer
c'est forcément le public c'est pas les
investisseurs privés qui vont payer donc
la vraie question c'est est ce que ça
coûte plus cher avec du public ou avec
du privé et là encore la réponse est
claire ça coûte moins cher quand c'est
des investissements publics
on peut faire des comparaisons
internationales qu'on veut edf monopole
public c'était peut-être c'était
peut-être un cas mais c'était considéré
comme un succès par tout le monde y
compris par ceux qui voulaient
libéralisé en angleterre par exemple
et aujourd'hui c'était des entreprises
préférées des français règlent le prix
d'électricité a été un des moins chères
d'europe aussi pour le choix du
nucléaire mais mais aussi parce que ça
fonctionnait très bien la qualité était
bien et aujourd'hui on a
considérablement dégradées le système et
les usagers disent qu'ils ne veulent pas
choisir leur fournisseur ils veulent
qu'on leur livre une électricité au
moindre prix et de qualité
mahmoudi est oui alors vous rappeliez
tout à l'heure j'étais j'ai eu cette
chance et cet honneur directeur europe
d'edf justement dans les années 2000
celle où l'idée c'était que des f
devienne une grande entreprise
européenne
au fur et à mesure que comme dans tous
les autres pays d'europe
on admettait qu'il y ait une concurrence
qui s'instaure aussi en france et bien à
ce moment là il était normal judicieux
qu'il y ait la capacité pour edf de
pouvoir se développer ce qui a été fait
et avec beaucoup de succès dans dans
certains domaines et sa pas été non plus
une source par quelques aventures
sud-américaine de pertes
il ya eu des succès considérables et des
plus values notamment la revente des
réseaux en grande bretagne après avoir
été acheté à rapporter beaucoup d'argent
à l'entreprise c'était aussi pour elle
un moyen de financer sur l'explosion on
est revenu à une autre vision pour
certains on se recroqueville sur le
territoire national à part quelques
grands dossiers quelques grands projets
comme celui de nick layton dont on parle
et qui est lié la continuation de
filière nucléaire je reproche pas edf de
faire ses activités jeudi que simplement
ils peuvent pas tout faire
comme aucune entreprise au monde est la
différence avec le privé madame c'est
que si jamais ça se passe mal on sait
que c'est là le contribuable qui est le
garant qui va payer c'est pas les
actionnaires privés qui vont perdre leur
mise
voilà et je pense que cet excellent
qu'un certain nombre d'acteurs
s'intéressent à notre pays vient y faire
d'eux des des investissements et dans
des domaines qui sont par nature des non
délocalisables un camp si vous
construisez des barrages aussi vous
plutôt des turbines ou ou s'ils
modernisent et toute la partie
hydroélectrique c'est pas pour être
transportés ailleurs le lendemain matin
donc voila un petit peu l'ambition qu'on
devrait retrouver pour edf c'est à dire
une grande société quelques elle est
toujours capable grâce à sa force même
de ne pas avoir peur de la concurrence
mais de lui faire une place
et puis je pense que tous les citoyens
verront qu'au fur et à mesure et se
passera dans l'électricité ce qui s'est
passé dans le gaz
il y avait quelques années un monopole
absolu du gaz avec gdf vous savez
aujourd'hui
angie c'est moins de 50% des parts de
marché et il ya une concurrence qui a
qui a cru et les prix vont d'ailleurs
considérablement du gaz ont
considérablement baissé
donc j'espère qu'il pourra y avoir aussi
quelques pistes dans ce domaine
question subsidiaire marais visiter marc
boudier mais vous me répondez en une
minute
est-ce qu'il est souhaitable à vos yeux
que les les indépendants puissent un
jour produire du nuc de l'électricité
nucléaire ou de oui-oui hydraulique est
ce que vous pourriez 5 pour l'instant
vous ne pouvez pas le faire mais ce que
vous souhaitez le faire un jour oui mais
bien sûr mais je peux vous dire c'est
déjà le cas seulement ils font pas en
france parmi les membres de la fieec
vous avez par exemple
des entreprises nordiques comme fortwo
mme comme vattenfall qui comme chacun
sait sont des entreprises nucléaires
également extrêmement spécialisé dans le
domaine des concessions hydroélectriques
il y à des suisses également qu'ils sont
également très actif dans le domaine
hydroélectrique
il ya des très grandes entreprises
françaises comme total qui demain
peuvent aspirer à essayer d'avoir un mix
énergétique avec d'ailleurs les
capacités pour pour développer et comme
on le sait dans des certains domaines
comme par exemple l'hydroélectricité en
tout état cause il reprendrait le
personnel qui existe aujourd'hui
donc oui c'est possible oui c'est
souhaitable et on espère que ça se
passera soit versée tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission est
rendu ce débat a priori compliquée
plutôt plus clair vous en remercie merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous dans
un prochain numéro
[Musique]